today is the day Shamar Franklin Moore
is about to find out if he's gonna be a
daddy
to a little girl or to a little boy I'm
about to be a father come February 8th
2023. yep Shemar Moore is just weeks
away from going from Daddy to real life
Dad I'm proud of what I've accomplished
on Monday the 52 year old's Criminal
Mind star shared the happy news on
Instagram posting a sweet clip from the
gender reveal party I'm just so excited
for this portion of our life together
and it's gonna be amazing
let's just say this wasn't your average
reveal I just got it
they're taking off at 3 30. yeah Shamar
and his girlfriend Desiree design
recruited a helicopter to assist with
the whole is it a boy or is it a girl
thing
I don't even know
[Applause]
[Applause]
yep it's a baby girl which gives a whole
new meaning to shamar's Criminal Minds
catchphrase
hey how you feeling baby girl yeah baby
girl what's going on you can do this
baby girl but before the couple learned
what they were having baby girl
Jamar gave us
three years ago and get this the
anniversary of her death February 8th is
the baby's due date
mama I did it Mama's in heaven I miss
her so much I wish she was here she's
smiling she's so proud wanted to make
this happen while you were here but
you're still a part of all of this the
actor paid tribute to his mom in the
caption writing quote Mama smiling from
Heaven miracles happen here comes the
best part of my life and all that Echoes
what Shemar told ET last year do you
want to feel that just love someday you
want to be a daddy still I do you know I
mean especially with the loss of my
mother you know and and you know she
left too soon she was only 76 years old
and and What Hurts the Most about losing
her is we had a plan everything you know
you know all through my life it was me
and her you know we started the day you
know checking on Mama and finish the day
and then I would go out in the day just
trying to make her proud in a sense
deleted Tick Tock shamar's girlfriend
recapped 2022 and fans speculate that
this brief clip is the moment she
reveals her pregnancy to Shamar we also
see her growing baby bump and the moment
Shamar gifted her with a new mom mobile
for their growing fam baby boy has
nothing but love for you and for those
who are curious Desiree's a model slash
actress with two kids already a teenage
son and a five-year-old daughter while
we don't know exactly how long she and
Shamar have been together we do expect
to learn more on the Jennifer Hudson
show on January 26th that's when jamar's
big interview about baby airs I was
worried for a while that maybe that ship
had sailed kind of thing and and you
know God had my back and things lined up
and uh it's going to be the best part of
my life is pretty Grand but I know
whenever God does Call My Name once I
get this experience I'll be able to go
to heaven holes
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]